turkey has sent doctors and medical
supplies to Somalia to treat the dozens
injured in Saturday's truck bombing at
least 80 people were killed in Mogadishu
Somali as president is blaming the armed
group al-shabaab and he's vowing the
country won't be demoralized by the
worst attack for two years
harue Mutasa is covering developments
from Nairobi in neighboring Kenya well
right now we told that the security has
been slightly increased in Mogadishu
there are a bit more police officers and
soldiers particularly at security
checkpoints in terms of other things the
focus right now really seems to be on
treating the injured a lot of hospitals
are unable to cope with the number of
people who have been injured and the
seriousness of the injury so Turkey has
sent in medical equipment and also a
medical team and that team is on the
ground trying to treat people who've
been injured those who are critical had
been evacuated
we told 15 people have been sent to
Turkey so that is the main focus for
most people right now especially those
with family members who are lying in
hospitals waiting to be treated the
general sentiment on the ground from
people's that they are angry they keep
asking why does it take so long or why
is it always these attacks keep
happening and nothing really seems to be
done about there growing impatient they
tired of seeing their loved ones die and
the government is under a lot of
pressure a lot of pressure to improve
the security situation in Somalia but
right now everyone seemed to be focused
on trying to treat as many people as
possible and for now we know the latest
is 15 people have been evacuated to take
it the equator is an independent Africa
policy analyst he says it's time for the
world to make a serious effort to tackle
armed groups in Africa the support from
the international community has not been
zero let me let me say that but having
said that in my opinion my strong
opinion it is insufficient it is less
than what somalia needs and it's not
just Somalia the al-shabaab has attacked
Kenya the avatar began de then if you
swing over to Western and North Africa
there are terrorist groups all over so
Africa has a real terrorist problem
I live in Washington and I don't get the
sense that the Western countries take
terrorism in Africa seriously they think
it's a secondary problem they blame
African governments they say well the
government is not perfect the government
has has corruption so until they clean
up their act they they have to deal with
it I think that is wrong they we have to
use the same yardstick when the
terrorist victims are weather in Europe
weather in the Middle East or weather in
North America we have to understand that
we need to bring dissident groups into
the political circle to talk but if they
pick up arms then the state must
suppress them so that innocents are not
killed we need to protect African lies
the same way we protect otherwise